hey it's Joey and welcome to better
ideas I was just sitting in my apartment
and realized that I really needed to do
my laundry and I've been putting it off
for like the past two days or so you
know I'm a busy guy and every time I
thought about doing my laundry I was
like anyways thankfully I remember this
awesome trick that always helps me snap
into the procrastination funk and just
gets me to do the thing that I'm
avoiding it's actually one of the
simplest tricks in the book and it's
called the three to one rule all you do
is this damn I should really do the
laundry three two one
do it you just count from 3 to 1 and
then you do the thing that you're
avoiding it sounds stupidly simple and
before you go in like dislike the video
for you go write it off as BS give it a
try it's a lot more powerful than you
think it is and there's a reason for
that it's because counting out loud
doesn't seem so hard but it acts as a
bridge between the thought of doing
something and actually doing it counting
is a lot easier than doing so you're way
less likely to procrastinate counting
but once you start counting you're
already taking a step in the right
direction of doing the thing so you've
gained momentum and that momentum will
carry you towards doing the thing so it
really doesn't sound that hard or that
profound but it's super powerful the
next time you're procrastinating doing
something just think in your head 3 2 1
guarantee you'll do it this trick can
work for anything even subscribing to
this channel I'll still haven't
subscribed three two one